all right
let's do
here we go
looks like we live
right
what you doing
beach street boys buddy off diapers
pogo studios yashban throughout
gupta about joseph stark apex i am g v
sandar and now it's going a little bit
too fast
indian games means that star wars guy
hello hello hello we are doing miss
marvel and kenobi tonight it is going to
be a long night
sue hello how's it going
mr anderson welcome to the chat
sue i had a korean bbq the other day and
i thought about you because i was
actually able to have
a somewhat decent conversation with the
the waiter in korean
i was proud of myself
hello hello hello hello
hello
hello everybody so we're gonna watch
miss marvel first and then uh obi-wan
second
that's the plan tonight so i hope
everybody's in for a decently long night
uh
greg with the re-real jax is texting me
right now so i'm texting him
uh
it's in 15 minutes
15 minutes star wars content's still
here
we're going to watch obi-wan immediately
after ms marvel
yes uh did i move stuff around yes i
actually kind of got a new studio
and uh
um i got a whole new i i can't really
turn it around i can't really show you
but i got a whole new
set up from elgato i signed a
partnership with them and my studio
looks fantastic now
uh like really really fantastic i'm a
little too close i'm
gonna get comfortable so yeah
um if things look a little bit different
they are a little bit different he's my
son aj
look at aj in the chat um hold on what
was i
i think someone asked if i was going to
go 7c17 i don't think i'm going to go
see 17 i am going to see itsy i'm
probably going to see aspa i just saw
twice like four times and they're my
favorite so
i love i love that so so much uh this is
miss marvel episode two and then we are
going to watch kenobi episode five
immediately after nicholas or now what's
greg's number five five
five five five five
uh i can't the way everything is set up
right now y'all i can't really do a
studio
tour what if i do this
yeah i mean this is like my face cam
that's
i mean you can see kind of more of
everything like
that's captain america figure that's
a thor thing this is spider-man g fuel
more spider-man g fuel
more stuff uh we're going this way funko
funko's you know
grogu what is down there that's a iron
man helmet
thor's hammer
lightsaber
stormbreaker hat i got from the moon
knight premiere
this is rocket
rocket
and yes i did name her
from rocket raccoon after rocker raccoon
i have kyrie down here but kyrie doesn't
like to be on camera apparently what's
going on my hair
we can fix that right
[Music]
sure why not whatever
you all know what i look like who cares
so back to this
[Laughter]
it's a little bit a little bit different
quality here a little bit different
quality
oh thanks sue
yeah
yeah that's why i'm doing the miss
marvel ones again because i know we uh
we used to
obviously we do every marvel one it was
a little bit weird you know last week
when we didn't do miss marvel even
though i love kenobi i love kenobi i
want to make some more videos about
kenobi and we are watching kenobi right
after this because
i'm really excited to see what happens
and i haven't seen miss marvel episode
two i have seen it um
i don't i was gonna say what can i tell
you about it but um
i'm not gonna tell you anything because
that i don't wanna spoil it we're about
to watch it uh we're about to watch it i
actually have
like
i have a spider-man helmet a darth vader
helmet
um
i have a really awesome gwen stacy
figure
that i need to here i'll show you guys
right now i need to show or i need to
set up
all right okay
oh no it's coming apart
look at this i gotta set this up so soon
i'm so pumped to set this up i wonder if
there's like a picture of what it
actually is
supposed to be like i don't think there
is
but it's so cool when i saw it on
display i was like oh my gosh i love
spider gwen she's my favorite i have to
i have to put this out i need to
i need to set this up and i have a miles
morales one where the heck is that i
know i have that somewhere i have so
much stuff
focus on my face
there we go i have so much like
collectible stuff that i just haven't
i have so much stuff guys i buy so much
stuff and i'm like oh this is gonna be
really cool this is gonna be really cool
this is gonna be like so cool for my uh
for my studio and then like right here i
have what is this
like i meant to set this up for doctor
strange
and we're way past doctor strange
like i just have stuff lying around
everywhere
so yes a vader helmet
a lot of different funkos a lot of
different i have that's that's spider
ham
wolverine loki vader helmet spiderman
helmet i hear the spiderman helmets
too
small
and that's why i haven't opened it yet
so well we'll see
i thought i was gonna have an extra one
to give away and you could probably buy
them now i think maybe i don't know
um
you should not be able to buy them
uh it looks like you could buy
yeah you could buy some online now they
used to be sold out for like a really
really long time
one word don spoiler review for episode
two
uh
but
it's hard to think of something that
that
won't spoil
i will say
uh
you'll have some questions
by the end
uh
what do you mean why is the camera
flipped oh
because the cw is backwards
there's gotta be a way to do that right
oh
there we go
figured it out
what is going on okay so
yeah eight minutes till the episode
drops uh do i have marvel legos
of course
i've i've got so much stuff over here
um i have the infinity gauntlet one
sitting right there that i haven't done
yet that i need to do
um i've got a lot i've got lots of legos
how many miss marvel episodes did i
watch soup just the first two so i've
seen this episode
i've seen this episode
um
disney x1 september
dinosaur i i think it's gonna be big i
really do i i genuinely believe
we're gonna get some phase five stuff
like they've announced so much for phase
four
um
and they've kind of just like announced
things because keep in mind like they
announced phase four
like in 2019 right and then
and then
uh
the pandemic and everything happened and
then they announced like new things
and didn't like specify what phase they
were in so i think things like armor
wars and like the wakanda series that
they're that they're making and stuff
like that i think that's all phase five
i i think we're about to get to because
remember they listed the entire phase
four right to the end of you know
quantum mania
guardians three whatever the last one
would be whatever the last one would be
so
i think the new stuff is phase five uh
tj banks i i really hope they don't just
put the x-men in another universe i
i think that would be a big middle
finger to us especially you know
we've all really been waiting for the
x-men to come so
yeah uh we are doing obi-wan tonight
guys for those asking we're gonna do it
right after miss marvel
gonna do it right after miss marvel
so don't worry about that
stake force what hope
um
i've kind of given my real thoughts on
miss marvel i'm kind of just here for
the ride at this point
i don't think it's the most fantastic
thing to come from marvel but i'm not
bored
um
i'm not a teenager high school was
really a long time for me uh
so
i can definitely understand the appeal
and it's entertaining for sure and i
really like the animation it reminds me
of scott pilgrim versus the world
there's a lot i like about it and
there's some that i just don't really
care for it you know
so
i definitely don't dislike it but it's
not one of my favorite mcu projects
granted i've only seen two episodes
right i'm trying to keep an open mind um
it could have the best finale ever you
know what i'm saying but for me it's
still like loki's like up there y'all
you know what i mean
like oh this this is not shut i need to
shut this lid
canadian blood what is up man i think
we're all waiting for your 0.25
uh breakdown of all this stuff canadian
leads in the chat yo
we go way back
we go way back
i knew him
when he had like
when did we first email man uh
man you had like not even 100k and now
look at you all the success to you man i
wish you all the success
i always tell like all my buddies greg
over the real rejects
paul heavy spoilers
uh chris cosmic culture like my brother
i'm helping you youtube i hope they all
pass me i re i hope i'm the small
youtube channel i hope all my friends
pass me i wish them all the success in
the world
you know
you gotta root for your friends you
gotta watch out for the people who don't
root for you
those are the ones
there's like the famous code it's like
be like notice the people who don't clap
when you achieve something right when
everyone's clapping for you notice who
doesn't clap for you because those
people are gonna stab you in the back
you gotta root for your friends you
gotta root for your friends hey louis
barry
do you like this or pilot episode
pilot oh man i don't want to like say
things like to like to there's different
aspects to this and i think
anytime we're introduced to a new
character it's really fun and it's
really exciting oh that's like loud i
need to put that in my head set hold on
oh yeah that's in the speakers
headset
sure we'll say uh
we'll say
what some of y'all don't know everybody
just keeps saying canadian lad and me
collabing we've collabed before
but i realize i have a lot of new
followers canadian has a ton of new
followers so
some people might have missed that some
people might have missed it
the tree syrup blood that's pretty funny
literally like loki just stabbed you in
the back seal yup yup
knish agarwal yep we're trying to get uh
we're trying to get uh 1 million
things have been kind of uh i think
i think a lot of people are waiting for
a thor 11 thunder to come out
uh i
i i do have merch coming
i hope i don't have to wait till i hit 1
million for it but it's it's literally
being made right now like literally i
have screenshots of it all being printed
uh so yeah let's go ahead and
we should pop open disney plus here
i actually have all my notes
i'll share them with you so quickly
oh
oh look my notes for miss mart for miss
marvel episode two can you see him
sorry to do that to you guys
this is the notes for my breakdown for
miss marvel episode 2.
screenshot it as fast as you can
marvel
why won't you let me click on it there
we go
so i ordered a brand new computer i
spent i dropped a lot of money into it i
went all out
because this pc is screwing up and um
it's like delayed by like three freaking
weeks i'm like come on i even paid for
it to be like quickly made
and then they're like oh we don't have
the case oh we don't have the ssd card
like oh my gosh
i
louis i appreciate the super chat but
you say don't say if it's true
so it's like if i say nothing at all
i guess you don't really get an answer
anyway
um
i don't know i'm not going to say this
you said don't you said that
you know
we'll see
we'll see we'll see i'm not trying to
spoil anything right before it comes out
in one minute i believe
wait spoiler for what what are what are
we looking at the spoiler what did i say
a spoiler i'm confused what happened
what did i say
can i rank every marvel
series first shot uh i actually have
that coming up
i don't i don't think i finished it yet
i've started this record
i've started to regret
i'm i'm trying to i'm trying to like
did i spoil something i don't even
remember
it's a comment it's out you're no oh my
my nose my notes all right um oh i also
need
mr anderson what do i normally do stop
watch stop watch
i'm gonna stop watch um i am about to
start this episode
we're gonna start in three
two
one
generation what no wait now that's the
first episode
i take it back we're not starting
we're not starting
now go back
three two one
crushed oh yeah
so a little fun fact i actually watched
this today because i was doing my
breakdown
but
i will say
i can't hear crap
and i still can't what
i can't hear i can't hear this
what is happening
there we go i hear it
all right it's just a recap right now
i need captions on because i do not have
captions on the ones that disney sends
me
subtitles
english
sweet
hey happy thank you for that super chat
great content bro keep the great work i
super appreciate that
hope you continue to enjoy it
lewisberry hope for some really good
lawyers
all right
we have started here we go
i'm actually excited to watch it with
the closed captioning because some parts
i was like seriously what are you saying
i i can't
paxton i see the frog
oh mr anderson
did i do
there it is
and boom
let me see if that's matched up yeah
it's perfectly perfectly matched up
you can't see it so blacked out
hi clancy
ant-man powers
that she kind of takes me back to high
school and like
i don't like it
whoops
why
don't do it
you can't reveal your identity
the budget captain marvel and she's
excited to be called that because
captain marvel's her favorite
ray youtube is my main job
her name is not nightlight
i hate how she acts like she knows
like she knows the superhero it's like
dude she clearly just saved you you
don't know her
come run
pretty sure i figured out who he is i'll
let you guys guess
now you want to go to the party
uh guys i can't share my screen i mean
i'll show you what happens if i share it
look nothing it's just black disney has
figured out a way to
oh you can see the subtitles
do you see that down there you can
actually see the subtitles but it's just
a black screen disney
disney figured out how to how to block
it somehow
thank you guyani baba
i saved you because you almost killed me
superhero training
yeah i used to be able to share the
screen and then
it was like moon night all of a sudden i
couldn't
no this is an interesting part
for coming from within you
that's just like a cheesy part of like
terrigen mist like
duh
so i'm curious if if like the bengal
unlocks the like whatever's inside
somebody i want to know like what
happened if
bruno would put it on
hard light
it's morbid time
that's a raven vibes that's funny
ah thanks whose reactions appreciate
that
mr anderson i'm not sure why you said
nice warren
did i miss something
i miss something
i had to actually do some research here
for on like uh mosques
and uh
um
like the religion muslim like i had to
learn a little bit about it
to actually kind of
get like a deeper feel of the episode
which i like i like doing like i really
liked moon night because i liked uh
learning about kind of like the egyptian
mythology and stuff like that it was
really fun it was really interesting
oh it's morbid time
um
james i i've watched some anime
an old school dragon ball z fan
our modesty and dignity
everything looks good on the stream good
good good we doing well we're doing well
cool
totally run
oh i've watched an hour too for sure
watched on her toe
the musk shoe thief
that sucks
at your place of worship
so
aunties and uncles are kind of what they
call you know like all the older
male and females
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're at their actual aunts and uncles
for those who don't know
oh yeah like the last time she like
interacted with her mom was when she got
caught right
yeah i think so
we haven't really seen it this episode
i need you to stay safe
you already know there's some family
history that like
they're gonna hash out soon
adventure con 2.
episode 2 has aired we are watching it
right now we're 12 minutes into it
her mom said yes
miguel's hovering
the scene is right from the comics
from the comics that's zoe's boyfriend
plus some vodka she's like 16 dude
and he's probably like 17.
she takes one sip
of orange juice with vodka in it and
goes am i drunk
i just double back flipped
hey enchantrex what's up welcome welcome
welcome
marcos what's up dude
see i can relate to that i've i've been
there i've
i've been
kind of like
struck by the crush
not going to do time for being at a
party
come on bruno don't be jealous don't
show it you can't show it
you can't show your jealousy bruno
that's not how you get the girl have you
watched any movie ever
which ironically is going to be a scene
coming up
about any movie ever
all right these are the names i couldn't
make up before
basically
that's bollywood stuff
oh bruno
oh bruno
if i were there i'd be pulling him in
the backseat like
be quiet you sit in the back seat you
don't embarrass yourself man i got you
bruno is like a little puppy
a little puppy little
puppy dog love
yeah i'm the same guys i want bruno and
kamala to get together
there's a classic move right here
he calls him brian that's a classic
stupid guy move you call the other guy
the wrong name
he does know your name's not brian
he playing those games
it's a little bit more smoother than you
bruno sorry
uh what do you mean ray what do you mean
bruno has to be muslim
see i can see how like a lot of people
would like this scene but i don't find
it too appealing i'm just kind of like
hmm
i think pretty soon toa
oh mr hanson you love it
i'm just kind of like
i get how like a 16 year old girl
that's how she would be
totally get it
she's definitely perfect for the role
i don't think anyone could really argue
that she's pretty dang perfect for the
role
uh-oh
[Music]
woman shove your nose into a book
she calls her kk
oh jd ultra i think they said
i can't remember when they said this
takes place
okay
next
kk and next i like it it's cute
uh ace yeah it's worth checking out for
sure
i think i
i think it's like there with hawkeye
ray if your muzzle it's called a hijab
is that what it is what she wears is
it's uh or ricky anyone who's muslim in
the chat that's called a hijab what she
wears on her
head right in her neck
the mic like completely off
yeah a hijab sweet
i did it what's going on lord stark
yeah yeah marcus i like uh
i like the scott pilgrim vibe excuse me
oh this part is all talking about the
movie
it's kind of funny
i like this guy he's funny
you're sitting down as he looks at him
sitting down
he looks like marty mcfly
but kamala's not there
have you ever seen a movie
yes i've seen a movie
devil where's parada
he's right he looks like marty mcfly
like almost exactly
i'm meryl streep
ever seen a movie
it's in california where kamala
is not
uh yeah ray we're watching it right now
that's what we're doing that's what the
timer is that we're 22 minutes into the
episode
oh look there's mr dreamy eyes
it
she's got a date brandon i'm sorry but
she's got a date
it's all right bruno i'm gonna coach you
and you're gonna get her no big deal
guys just so you know we are watching
kenobi after this
just keep refreshing phoenix it should
pop up sometimes disney plus kind of
lags a little bit
so she fails her driver's license but
he's like yo
drive my dad's porsche no big deal
i would never
i don't let people drive my cars
israel did kinko get mission mentioned i
missed it
oh kingo
yeah okay i was a little behind
and a senior that's so funny
king go
not even licensed and
and
right into porsche
you see what she did there she's like
maybe someday you'll feel like jersey's
your home she's like already thinking
about marriage she like wants him to
stay there forever i love this like
crush that she has on him
marcus that's hilarious
oh
[Music]
he's our cousin
um
look how he changes that accent that's
pretty good man
no but she sees right through
oh fun
yeah you're not wrong israel i bet you i
bet you
yeah i bet you miss marvel and
spider-man would get along
hot topic
thanks jojo tube appreciate that
spiky jewelry
i never went through a goth phase i went
through a punk phase but never a
a goth phase
almost anything not not a goth punk
foreign
this part's important
trail of stars like the ones that she
kind of makes with her bracelet
she disappeared that night
i have my theories they're coming out in
tomorrow's breakdown
the evil eye
yeah no spoilers for kenobi we're
watching it right after this
i've got cat hair in my mouth i think
wait the post we have emails now
aisha okay
we are watching ob after this yes
carol danvers poster
i mean they're everywhere
he's such a good actor
cover band of bon jovi
laughs
oh she didn't know that name before
bon jovi mcu cannon now
me too no name me too
foreign
thank you yo joe tube
youner
the dopest
oh this is funny this is kind of like a
funny part
i'm sure i said that wrong
it's it's pretty bright
politics
gossip gusset gossip
the illuminantes
i love that
the mask bros
excuse me
insta click
yeah it does mr anderson something i can
never grow
the illuminante i love that play that's
so funny
i mean i can't grow a beard like that i
can grow a decent beard but not like
that not like a really good beard
rasheed
uh nikia is just the best guild tripper
right here
thanks typical caleb
two
i don't know what
that means classic flip book
huh what is he doing is he's getting
guilt-tripped and suckered into
into voting for your competition there
buddy and here look who it is
he is playing you
enhanced individual
mom's the scroll
i kind of hate this woman right here
this agent
yeah right lily swindon mr anderson
he got ned and now he got zoe
mosque
i want to know who these guys really are
i feel like
i feel like they have something to do
with
the cree or the scroll
i really feel like they have something
to do with the create the scroll
i'm not buying it
a snake
yeah i'm i'm definitely thinking the
creek connection especially building up
into secret wars
right sorry we're secret invasion in uh
the marvels
definitely
thinking some crazy stuff's going down
here
and this kid's just the brightest kid
there is like yeah good job buddy
what the [ __ ]
i don't think they want anything with
the young avengers i think i think they
i think they want the bracelet i think
they
recognize that power i bet you the
bracelet is cree and they're like a
scroll
probably wanting that power
hey thanks edmund
mctigue
admit take thanks man
it's night light i wonder when they're
going to start calling our miss marvel
that's a question i asked too buddy why
did you do that
what's your favorite thing
who's gonna try this
ice cream pizza
huh
come on come on you got to get the
confidence
night light
what's up who's a smith
run
wait a second
were those the kia shoes
they kind of looked like nikki's shoes
all right i wanna who's gonna try ice
cream pizza first because it's not gonna
be me
superhero landing
and social media famous
yeah i'm hoping miles appears in
spider-man 4.
thank you as io smith appreciate that
oh she missed
but she kind of saved him
she kind of did it mr anderson
ah no name
deadpool love it
thank you beauty samuel thank you
appreciate that
uh what are these i really thought aim
was gonna be behind all of this
i don't think so much anymore i
definitely think it's like a cree scroll
thing
also curious to what technology this is
get in
it's really interesting how he knew that
she was miss marvel right
and he just so happened to be there and
how are these people looking around like
they don't know what just happened
you're very cool israel
look who it is
ah
is there a post-credit i don't remember
there being one
i don't think there's a post credit
i don't think they're supposed to credit
all right i am i'm switching to kenobi
right now
because i'm gonna be up all night doing
breakdowns
i'm not wasting time
i do have to like change the title and
everything of all my stuff though so
no post credit scene yeah the first the
first one had one
so the part
five yeah they just call them the fives
okay so we're gonna reset this and i
have to change thumbnails and stuff
i'm also not really sure how to do all
that while i am live
um
so we're gonna edit this now
kenobi episode five
could no be
episode five watch party and discussion
same thing here cano b
episode not two
five watch party and discussion
could no
be
star wars
uh what do you mean going to get behind
the scenes of everyone marcus
i don't think i need to switch videos
guys but you know what i'm gonna do real
quick
i'm gonna give christopher a call
do you have to stop your stream and
start it to change the title and the
thumbnail
uh no just go into
your youtube
editor what about stream labs
sorry do you need to do anything on
stream labs
no you didn't touch streamlabs just go
into youtube and change it
okay starting kenobi
i am starting kenobi as well okay cool
yeah we'll go bye
all right let's check it out seems like
we should be all right now
although nothing has changed so
okay we're going to go in here and edit
this
even though i just did all this
kanobi
episode five that's four okay
kenobi
i put i kenobi like he's an iphone he's
not an iphone
what what is the joke like that's f and
obi-wan
all right
let's change this thumbnail kenobi
survive
okay the title changed the thumbnail has
not changed yet
so
um
so the lady in the car is uh
her name is najma
um
i don't know the relation to
kamala i don't know if she's like
related to her i don't you know because
that would actually mean her and comrade
are
actual cousins
so it's i don't think that's her
great-grandmother it's not her
grandmother because the person they were
talking about is her great-grandmother
so uh
it's not her it's not her grandmother
and i think like her great-grandmother
definitely not that young so i don't
think that i think it might be like her
aunt or something i have my oh i have my
own theory uh that's gonna come out with
my breakdown it's like the first thing i
talked about in the breakdown and i
connected through the comics and i also
think
i also think that uh
i also think that they're gonna do some
right kind of character uh yeah no we're
sue we're doing a discussion right now i
was just getting everything ready for
kenobi and then we're also gonna do the
discussion for kenobi after as well
um
i think it's gonna be like so here's the
deal i think that so she's the villain
i know that like
what is this
i know for a fact that the lady
cam comrade's mom i always want to say
cameron comrade's mom is the villain of
the show
what does that make comrade
i don't know i think he's red dagger i
think red dagger is going to kind of get
ret gone like two characters into one
because
um
comrade is not red dagger in the comics
and i believe comrade in the comics is
white but he has like
the power to like like his skin like
glows like a blue but i think like the
actual person like is white um
yeah so i think i think it's gonna be i
think that the the woman
najma
is the villain but
is she related i don't know maybe an
aunt
a random rebecca like you were saying
aunt or cousin or something like that um
maybe related somehow
maybe related through marriage so it
doesn't make it weird that she has a
crush on comrade so it's not like an
actual you know like
related type of thing
so
we'll have to see on that but i do for i
do fully believe that comrade is red
dagger
um
i've see we've seen red dagger in
trailers
and
was another guy cast this red dagger i
was trying to figure that out today
bombshell blurred
let's look that up
who is red dagger and miss marvel
uh
i
i had like looked for like a little bit
of that today i didn't know
i
i didn't know if someone had been cast
to play that character i looked and
what's funny is like i did notice that
in
one of the trailers red dagger has long
hair
and comrade has short hair
so i was like oh maybe they're not the
same person
you know maybe maybe they're not the
same person
oh wait what is this who is this right
here
this says actor
it's kind of blurry
armist knight
rms knight miss marvel
is there any
truth to this
all right so armist knight
uh
enormous nice actress
uh
he says
he's
just trivia says that he's
played multiple
characters in the mcu
uh rms knight portrayed kareem red
dagger in miss marvel interesting so
so i wonder who comrade is
i'm curious about that that's that's
actually pretty interesting to me
that's pretty interesting to me i know
um
najma's the villain does that make
comrade bad
i don't know
uh to mim yeah the dodc are acting super
sus i think they're probably scroll or
cree
because i definitely think the bengal is
like creed technology so it's either
skrull wanting it or cree trying to get
it back or something like that
joker i'm too high and confused
um basically that's the woman who she's
kind of been having
visions of all column visions um if
that's what we want to call them
um
but i i
i know she's
bad i think she's trying to take the
bengal i think there's some history
there
that goes back to pakistan
to where
she maybe had something to do with her
great-grandmother disappearing i don't
think her great-grandmother
is like the reason
how do i how do i how do i put this like
they say that their
her great-grandmother brought like shame
to them and everything like that
i don't i think that's a big
misunderstanding i think her
great-grandmother probably had the
bengal and was probably a superhero but
was framed
by like this ladies family right i think
like that ladies like relatives they
tried to get the bengal from her
something bad happened and kamala's
great grandmother got blamed for it and
then all the shame came blah blah blah
blah that's what i think is happening i
think by the end of the series
we're going to find out that like
kamala's great-grandmother was actually
like this really good person this really
good superhero and it's like now
kamala is now she's miss marvel like
it's like you know she like inherited it
and in one of the trailers actually
it's called seek
i believe
seek marvel studios seek
i think that's the trailer title that's
weird that i remember that um
there's
i all these names are like confusing me
najma
the woman who's in the car and the woman
who's in the vision
she says something like you've inherited
this power or something like that right
and keep in mind
something i want to talk about is that
bruno so many names to remember bruno
he said when he's like
all of a sudden it has like thermal
scanning on his ipad
uh which i found very funny but um
he said that the power is like coming
within her it's not coming from the
bengal it's activated the powers within
her i'm like okay it's like a play off a
target miss right like the terrigen
missed activates the power that's inside
blah blah blah blah blah i was like okay
would have rather had to tear your miss
but
i get it marvel we're going places um
yeah willie they're uh
they're
dodc is like ah they're not cool
they're they're either really not cool
or really cool and like really trying to
prevent like secret invasion or
something like that
um
yeah i just i
yeah who did it say that actor was
um
rms knight yeah i think he is playing
marie uh kareem
slash
red dagger
now um and thank you to
bombshell blurred for pointing that out
who knows who he may be maybe he's an
inhuman
who knows
yeah andrew russell what's up dude
did heavy spoil it did paul already post
his breakdown
oh yeah
well i'm still going to begin my we're
about to watch kenobi but i do think
cleary is a scroll yes david conlon
i think
there's they're either doing cree stuff
or scroll stuff and i'm thinking scroll
stuff is probably where we're going
especially with secret invasion coming
up for sure i definitely think that so
um
yeah so guys i'm gonna use the restroom
and then we're gonna watch kenobi
episode five and i'm super pumped for
that um while i'm gone type your
thoughts about miss marble episode miss
marble miss marvel episode two in the
chat i'll be right back gonna use better
did my cat rocket entertain everybody
rock it
rock it
what are you
doing meow oh silly kitty
this is rocket
oh i love her so much
hi
and she loves me hi that kind of hurts
i rock it
yeah sue i i don't think it was as good
as the first one either i was trying to
avoid saying that because i didn't want
to like
you know set that before going into this
i rock it hey
but yeah i like the first one better you
ready to watch kenobi
you ready to watch kenobi hmm
you wanna watch kenobi
okay
that's rocket
she
all right here we go
you guys like cats
kenobi time where we at uh
where are all my tabs
this tab all right
kenobi episode 5 is titled part 5.
uh mr anderson we get this timer ready
we're gonna start in five
four
three
two
one
there are certain scenes in this
fictional series that some viewers may
find disturbing
is that what i just said
that viewers may find upsetting wow
okay
kenobi time
my brightness is like really low i can't
really see
let's do it
oh yeah then the guy died because he
he didn't leave
oh yeah it's with lola leave lola alone
lola's tired of getting crushed and i'm
tired of watching her getting crushed
it's morbid kenobi time
comorbin time
kenobin norben kenobin
how does my stream look if i lower the
lights just a tad bit
yeah that's fine right yeah
because they're kind of bright
yo where are we at now
oh whoa
no way
dude
i'm already freaking out
oh
dude i'm already freaking out at this
dog dude i'm just so excited that we saw
that
yeah stream still looks fine with the
lower lights a little bit oh man
oh she's seeing him in person well she
was in person before
he came to her
oh he approves of her
i want to know what's going on
neil
oh he's gonna he's gonna oh she's gonna
be the grand inquisitor
yep
dude she got the badge
at once
all right i'm already loving this
episode i hope it stays like this holy
crap
yeah kevin qui-gon's gotta appear right
we gotta see a force ghost of qui-gon
but at what cost
hey
huh
dang
the path will protect us dang
you better do some more because they're
coming you better hurry up
lock down the facility
i was wondering if we're going to see
anything about quinlan voss
the question is does lola know she's
being
hacked
doesn't look like it
oh
yeah they look like they have full
control over low though
come on kenobi since it
oh oh i can't see
oh
dude what
what
like how do i adjust my freaking
brightness
i'm a little bit of behind i'm gonna
pause the timer real fast
who are those lightsabers all belong to
cause i trained him yeah so more of this
yes yes
oh
there it is
i wonder how many of these people are
going to dies you had a lot of
younglings there huh
vader's favorites
oh
gosh
i want to know who all those lightsabers
belong to
that's a good thing there's not like 20
doors
so how long until vader's like fine i'll
do it myself and he just comes down
oh
what happened what did i press go back
there we go is this vader
or is it the grand inquisitor the grand
inquisitor
yeah this episode's great so far jc
i want to know her story
[Laughter]
come on ice cube son let's go
ah is she gonna find lola
how did she just gonna know all the
stuff she's just gonna
dang
dang
i need a message out bro
can't have luke you jeopardize what's up
ballers locked
i really hope she doesn't die
i did finish miss marvel ballers lock
sorry
but now you're gonna help
yep
i like it
come on ben time to fight
go face vader
yo i want to see freaking obi-wan just
take on that whole freaking army
how did he communicate okay whatever
oh i'll accept it
is are they going to open the doors
she's gonna try to shove a lightsaber
right through there buddy
huh
yeah
yeah
that was like a that's like a big thing
you are a youngling
yeah about 16 minutes in it guys i just
found out that she was a youngling oh
flashback
oh the blue lightsaber
does she play dead
well
and you weren't there is what she's
gonna say
woof
that's a hard one
where were you exactly
mm-hmm
where were you
oh he was your paddle when she's hitting
him with all the
the
the stuff that he just questions every
night oh
better back the hell up everyone
i told you back the hell up
geez
oh
yes
everybody else grab lightsabers there's
like 10 of them there
it's a good thing stormtroopers can't
hit anything
oh snap
i just
no
i was hoping none of them died i guess
that was too much to hope for
dang
ding ding
no don't kill the droid don't kill the
droid it's gonna die no
oh i knew she was gonna get shot
gosh i really can't shoot with crap can
they
oh
that was sweet oh yeah just go punch him
dude i knew she was gonna die
come on tala
him too
i just knew it from the freaking
throw her throw her
come on obi save her
oh
she's gonna shoot the door
dang it man
that's oh
gosh this is that's exactly what i did
not want to happen that's intense
dang
oh that's like the freaking
i was calling it since like the third
episode that's what i did not want to
happen
oh
to stand down
yes more of these flashbacks please
it's over i have the high ground
dang
[Music]
all right all right all right
yo i'm really into this
noise
come on you gotta see lola there
oh she's gonna have to kill lola
did i miss what happened
to the
other inquisitors
did they die
i don't remember
interesting
i'm bringing him to you
no that's true
i like it i like it
that's what i thought
it was sway
how do you say your name josue
that's what i thought man
i think ob is expecting her to fight
wait
they took him back
but you can tell they did some cgi
oh he's he's coming down
oh i thought he was going up
all right guys i i can't read the chat i
don't want anything spoiled i'm gonna
block i'm blocking out the chat for a
second guys
mr anderson you're you got the you got
the comments because i'm uh i don't want
anything spoiled
don't let lola attack you
lola's back
now fix it lola
something about vader walking across the
bodies of dead storm troopers
is just so iconic
there you go
go go get out
get out run
does command on gianni die
i'm so confused they let kenobi go
they brought him back
always the best freaking music
the best music with vader man
no
obi's gotta be on the ground right
no way
obi where you at man come on ben
holy crap
are they not on it
they tricked him
dang
you can't do it again that took too much
that's awesome
you know that's sitting rent free in his
mind
this is he there
i know the grand inquisitor is there
she's dead
she's dead
you took too long girl you gotta like
rush home
doesn't even have a lightsaber
what is that gonna do
oh
is he gonna break it off and give her
one
oh
it's freaking shoves her with a force
dude that was sick
dang
oh
that's sad
i knew he knew he had to have known
oh that sucks
oh and the other grand inquisitor's back
okay
hmm
kill him at least kill him before you
die
use the force
crush his neck
poof
you should not leave her alive man
although you have proven that you are
i mean you're darth vader you're very
well more than capable
of dealing with her she's coming back
for sure
oof that's not good
is that hers is it put back together all
of a sudden
she's having some sort of an epiphany
now she knows
she knows of luke now
this is one of the greatest jedi masters
of all time
okay but
okay but she knows it but she's not
bad
i'm not seeing the post credit
seeing a post credit
okay
wow
wow
that was a pretty great star wars i'm
i'm not gonna lie
dude oh my gosh vader fighting without a
lightsaber
i don't understand
weird
i'm kind of confused about
because
riva's not
bad
so why is it such a disturbance in the
force
if she knows about him because she could
give him
she could give vader the info she
clearly wants to kill vader and they
clearly know
hmm
that was an amazing episode
wow wow
watching vader
watching vader just
beat her so badly
with just
the
force
and just
just mess with her oh my gosh that was
so crazy that was awesome that was like
i mean she had
her lights and oh my gosh i mean and
then he ripped it apart he grabbed one
threw one to her then he took it again
and he had both oh my gosh wow that was
that was a pretty great star wars i
i really really like that wow i actually
love that episode i would say
um
wow that was
that was pretty dang good uh
i mean him holding the ship back with
just the force
the finale
better be freaking dope
wow that was
that was a great
we haven't seen
have we really seen vader like that live
action
i don't think we have
i don't think they're yeah i don't i
don't i think we've seen vader like that
before
i mean holding a ship back with the
force fighting without a lightsaber
and then just destroying with a
lightsaber
but we still see that he's haunted
you know because it's still his old
master right and that what was the line
you know
he will still be a padawan until you
know he he
stops trying to basically like you know
prove something
so that's rent for in his mind right i
mean
i like i like how shows do that i like
how this show does that i like when
shows get
really like
deep
and like like okay so i did like a video
what a couple weeks ago
uh after episode two
and it was like um
oh yeah no you're right uh jose diaz
and i hope i'm pronouncing that right
i'm sorry if i'm not um yeah they're in
the end of the rogue one sing yeah that
was amazing but um
i did um
oh i did like why
vader let obi-wan leave
like remember after episode two we like
tortured him like in the fire and stuff
like that or was that episode three
either way
whatever one that was
i i did like you know why did why didn't
vader kill him then you know why did he
let him leave why didn't he why did he
escape and then you know a bunch of the
stupid people were like oh because
you know stop shilling it's because he
has to like appear
you know in episodes you know four five
and six it's like that's not
an excuse you can't say that there has
to be a story
right you can't just say oh vader didn't
kill him
because vader knew that they needed to
make a star wars movie like that's not
that's not a legitimate reason
right this is a real i mean it's not a
real story but like in this universe
these are real things happening
to these characters right who are
obviously fictional but
right there has to be justification
inside of that story inside of this
universe inside of their minds why did
vader let obi-wan leave because he was
toying with him right not because oh to
make the other movies like shut up like
that's so stupid like
i i
hate that so many people said that but i
mean whatever i don't really care um
uh you know granted i'm watching on my
computer i'm not watching on like a big
you know
really nice tv uh it didn't look that
bad to me the de-aging don't look that
bad to me
i did say hidden christians in a per in
person star wars celebration and uh
yeah he aged
he he aged they definitely need some of
that de-aging
definitely need some of that de-aging
but uh hey
uh
[Music]
i think this is the best episode so far
uh
i do think it i do think this is the
best episode so far i
10 out of 10. i'm a little confused at
the end um
i'm a little confused at the end because
also like one thing that happened
remember how they like he like
surrendered himself and the
stormtroopers took him and then and then
uh riva was like
did this and they took him back in
why did they take him back in like vader
wanted to break in himself like i that
part i don't necessarily understand
but yeah i didn't want tyler to die that
was pretty sad
i knew it was coming just because like
the way she was talking just like her
story arc and everything like
i knew it was coming
sadly enough
uh i'm tired
i would have thought at 2 30 in the
morning
but um oh man i'm really sad tala died
but
that was such a cool scene
that was such a cool scene and we
learned that riva was a youngling that
pretended to play dead who i
um
correct me if i'm wrong if i'm mistaken
she did get like
hit with a lightsaber like she either
got stabbed or something right and she
just laid and played dead
or you know other because i don't think
yeah yeah she must have got yeah
yes ned b gosh i didn't want him i
didn't want him to die either such a
great droid
such great droid and he like shielded
her at the end
um
luke knows a little bit about obi-wan
because he says you know i wonder if
he's talking about old ben kenobi so he
knows
i guess he doesn't know about obi-wan
but he knows ben so i'm wondering like
i wonder if there'd be an episode or
episode season two
i don't think so
but uh
i'll figure that out
but no i actually think this episode was
the best that we've seen so far from the
series and
i quite enjoyed it i would even say i
loved that episode i
anything with vader and like fighting
and lightsabers like
that whole act that whole sequence that
whole fight sequence i think was just
awesome
i just think that was a very very
awesome
uh sequence so
yeah
yeah
yeah i don't know how this the saber was
put back together
maybe they connect magnetically
maybe it was the grand and the other
grand inquisitors and he left it there
um
maybe it was a little cut scene that
seemed to get cut and we didn't see it
but yeah i do think that was the best
episode so far
all right i have a lot of work to do
so i'm gonna go ahead and
call it a night but
miss marvel episode two i didn't like it
as much as the first one i didn't want
to say that before we watched it uh
since i'd seen it before
um hopefully episode three is better
hopefully episode three gives us a
little bit of answers
i do think comrade is
maybe he's not totally bad
but
not najma his mom is bad and uh vader
episode five
i think it was great i can't wait for
the finale i hope they nail it i really
hope they nail it i really really really
enjoyed this series so far
and it would be a shame if they didn't
nail it uh after this episode i have
high hopes and uh obviously i'm
expecting a vader kenobi fight
and i hope it's not too short
i hope it's not too short i hope they
give it enough time and i hope they
really kind of
like
close it well like bring it to an end
really well that's that's what i hope
that's what i hope
uh so yeah
yeah
wait there was a spider-man connection
in this episode
did i miss it because i don't remember
it there was a king go connection they
talked about kingu which i thought was
pretty funny
i mean are they edith drones
that's kind of my question
you know
i'm wondering if they are edith drones
no i thought that but i
i just didn't know like is that a for
sure thing you know what i mean because
it it
kind of seemed like aim to me
but i know aim's not good i mean maybe
but i'm pretty sure it's like a cree
scroll thing but uh
but yeah
yeah i'll take a look at it again
yeah maybe i just missed it
good catch good catch
but yeah my eyes are as you can tell
very very tired now and i have to uh
i'm gonna have to get some sleep and i
have to do my breakdown as well so i'm
not gonna be getting to sleep for some
time now so i'm just gonna get started
uh oh no israel i totally you know i
totally thought i just didn't know if it
was like confirmed which is you know
which you can't really
unless they confirm it right you know
what i mean but yeah who knows
but uh yeah all right everybody um yes
kevin garcia maybe a qui-gon jinn you
know they've
he's mentioned him in two episodes three
episodes
two or three episodes
so hopefully he shows up to give him
kind of that you know motivation that he
needs that little boost of confidence
that he needs right before he fights
vader so
so yeah so all right guys uh hope you
enjoyed our watch party for miss marvel
and obi-wan episode five finale next
week there's one of those miss marvel
episode three next week super excited uh
big thank you to mr anderson for being a
mod check out his youtube channel if you
want uh he's getting started so any
support would help him he's linked that
below obviously subscribe to me if you
haven't and you want to
um
hey thanks julian gomez and uh yeah
we're gonna
and captain omega thank you thank you
thank you thank you um we're gonna be
here next week with uh two with a finale
and then episode three to miss marvel so
really really really excited for next
week uh sam thank you so much love you
all
i will see you next time